[Musica]
porca vacca il film è la di ragazze
benvenuto che sono video sono fa vj e
oggi siamo tornati su scrive l'ansa al
limite b perché c'è il tasto continua
non ho fatto niente ma come ho mio giro
non ci credo mai ma è rimasto il
salvataggio vecchio white ma eviti fondo
cento anni fa a micheletti poterla per
tra quattro anni fa
cazzo di massa il vecchio salvataggio
non ci posso credere
vi spiego ho voluto riaprire iscrive
alla sanità
dopo cinque anni cazzo powell è una
figata perché io sono questo omino tutto
figo la presa bella che posso fare che
ho questo quaderno magico dove se scrivo
il nome di l'oggetto questo compare
facciamo un esempio tipo valigie e
compare a vigere voi vi chiederete come
grazie possibile non lo so però è un
gioco veramente figo raccoglieva vj e
buttano nel bucano così gli haters sono
contenti ma aveva due si butti evito
regalo consegna parole mi sono preso lo
scettro il cambio di parigi è fighissimo
bastardo pezzo di merda niente le gambe
duro poco ma come cazzo può esserci
quella strada già assurdo faceva un muro
che sia tutto rotto muro nuovo ecco a
posto come voi che ripari questa cosa
sono così c'è scusa mi pare scotch
ecco qua sai perché c'è un bambino
neonato che sembrano qui sembravano le
buttate liriche morti ho bisogno di
qualcosa senza cervello
da subito come dietro pietro chi è tra
pietra tieni
va bene la pietra dal cervello per
zombie zombie zombie è senza cervello
zombie scrive zombie e ma fa niente
grazie ha funzionato
adesso c'è il cervello che piega fuga di
cervelli per che sponsorizzano i film di
paolo ruffini qua aiuta l'astronauta
prigioniero a scappare la prigione
aliena va bene tu gala palindromo da
inizia finalmente la missione decente
perché mi sono messo una maschera con il
problema a domandare alla navicella o no
la mia sorella è guasta con quatto la
tabella qui va bene meccanico sesso sto
gioco è più bella di quanto mi
ricordassi già è fantastico desidero un
po di cibo terrestre pollo al curry
azzurra pollo azzurro pollo tieni fatta
cucinare si micron microonde che ne sono
pasta pasta tema affacciano gas oppure
piatto aiutami a trovare un modo non
orale per comunicare con i marziani non
orale è come vuoi comunicare dal culo
fisarmonica e basta
vai col liscio ciao zio robocop voglio
sembrare umano cappello da cowboy
ecco qua non si che sei umano della
madonna che cosa è successo questo ciò
che meraviglia
dammi un superpotere usa blocca punti è
oggettivo gigante verde l'alto lento
fraudolenta va verso la caserma dei
pompieri o mio dio cosa è benvenuta la
caserma dei pompieri ciao ragazze tutte
le auto coppie sono occupate questa auto
deve diventare una canon camion dei
pompieri comincia a verniciando l'auto
vernice blu dipinge perfetto l'auto deve
essere punibile dai al dj qualcosa di
mio moroso degli antigeni cassa audio
perfetto esattamente e l'impianto audio
migliore che abbia mai visto zio il
pompiere quasi pronto ad intervenire
certo perché li sapeva la cassa
attaccata alla portiera per intervenire
bicchiere d'acqua di spegnere l'incendio
il bicchiere bellissimo se vi è comunque
un pierre e gas
l'auto del traffico terribile aiuta
l'auto superarlo cosa posso mettere per
far scappare la gente funziona
legalmente
porca eva schifoso lascia finalmente
togliete che deve salvare le persone
toglietevi quanto difficile al giorno
d'oggi faremo autori pontieri completato
54 perché c'è un'invasione di zombie
la città è stata invasa dagli zombie
ogni sopravissuto deve essere soccorso
aiuta il dottore a curare le ferite del
pompiere va bene che cosa vi possono in
un cerotto cerotto con sicuro che con
cerotti
sono sicuro che con i cerotti sei a
posto mi chiama gariglio ha staccato un
braccio e gli 11 notti per curarsi come
l'alfa nevi toso scossa bisogno di
qualcosa per calmarsi
il camomilla non ti piace uomo bello
fisicato fisico oddio oddio col fisico
pensavo di mettere i muscoli invece
fisico proprio studia fisica ma spara
sta roba almeno si spara spara poco
aspetta aspetta come come donald trump
muro perfetto prima di fare il
presidente donald trump ha giocato o
merda sono che poligonali attacca prima
di diventare presidente trump ha giocato
a scrive sarah da retata tazza cara mara
stata fino porca finito sono fatta
ragazzi al proposito dell'attacco dei
giganti e vorresti superare il muro
testa di culo è caduto
maria chimica è questo un folletto il
mio più ammesse impigliato nell'alto
aiutami a liberarlo dalla madonna svetta
tranquillo bimbo che metto subito io a
posto si è si è liberato
tieni divertiti dei ragazzi che possiamo
concludere qui è stato bellissimo
ritornare sul scriverla bellissimo spero
vi sia piaciuto ragazzo mi è piaciuto
tantissimo ritorna veramente ogni tanto
ci sta fa questa roba ci sta come
riuscirci al momento non mi piace anche
vari social comini totale scrizione
senza significativi ci fidiamo
[Musica]